j'suis pas
suivant
non
je m'appelle daniel logos je veux rendre
le monde meilleur
tout a commencé parce que j'en voulais
plus sinon j'étais parti pour 40 ans à
bosser en survêt
j'avais un plan pour changer tout ça
où tu étais en cabane état de new york
tu as des pistes pour du boulot je peux
pas enlever un mec elle dépouillé comme
ça c'est carrément illégales si on peut
victor cachant est un conte une espèce
d'escroquerie mérite des emmerdes
si on suit ancrage mal à personne au
show hilarant
on l'en barre pour qu'ils signent
quelques jours je te remercie
on lui fait prendre un mix de protéines
il sait même pas ce qui s'est passé
écoute j'ai matière attaque fume paul je
sais ce que je fais ces types ont réussi
à faire main basse sur tous vos biens et
ils en profitent maintenant
maintenant je me mets au boulot
[ __ ] parfait et titre
peut-être un peu aussi leurs parents
non